So here's a t-table that applies to statistical
estimates with fewer than 30 samples. And the
way to read through this on the left you see the degrees of freedom which is the
number of samples minus 1. So if you have 10 samples it would be 9, if there are
15 samples it would be 14. On the top, you'll see 1 minus the confidence level.
So if you want 95% confidence, you go to 0.05. If you
want 98% confidence, you go to 0.02. Now there's a slight
distinction here. There's a 1-tail and a 2-tails. So far, we've
talked about 2-tails in which, we always cut off tails left
and right of our confidence interval. There are occasions, which we'll
talk about later, where we should just cut off one side.
And those often occur in the context of testing
hypotheses. Now for the time being, please just look
at the 2-tails number over here. And ignore all
those 1-tail numbers in this table. Okay? So just
to make sure you know how to read this
table. Suppose we have n=8 samples and we look
for a 90% confidence interval. What number would you
find in this table to be the magic number?